at long last the Hyperloop has arrived
well kind of
Hyperloop one has successfully tested
the pod that will someday carry people
in cargo up to practically supersonic
speeds through a near vacuum tube the
company is the biggest player in the
race to realize Elon Musk's dream of two
based transportation and this is a big
box to check this past weekend Hyperloop
once engineers loaded the aluminum and
carbon fiber pod 28 feet long shaped
like a bus with the beak of an eagle
into the tube at their Nevada Test track
using magnetic levitation to hover above
its track and moving through a tube with
nearly all the air sucked out the pod
accelerated to 192 miles per hour in
just under a thousand feet the electric
propulsion system applied the equivalent
of more than 3,000 horsepower to the pod
which then braked to a calm stop so
running the pod faster and faster each
day we're going longer and longer
distances and we're getting closer to
deploying it throughout the world this
is just a proof of concept of course and
there's plenty left to do before you or
anybody else can climb aboard try
building a full-on system with things
like stations ringling down the cost of
infrastructure we're negotiating with
all of the public agencies needed to put
this newfangled system into practice
details details that slightly creepy
wail you hear that's the future and it's
on its way